well it's a pleasure to welcome Prime
Minister Netanyahu back to the Oval
Office I think I've had the pleasure of
hosting him more often than just about
any other world leader and hopefully
this will provide just some small
measure repayment for the wonderful
visit I had in Israel this spring and I
want to thank him in his family there's
an entire team for the tremendous
hospitality that we had one Prime
Minister and I were just talking about
the fact that these are hectic times and
nowhere is that more true obviously then
in the Middle East and so we had an
opportunity for a wide-ranging
discussion about a range of issues i
commended him for entering in good faith
negotiations with the Palestinian
Authority in discussing how we can
resolve what has been obviously where
the biggest challenges for a very long
time in the region and both Prime
Minister Netanyahu and President Abbas
have assigned outstanding negotiators
they have been engaging in serious
conversations and our goal continues to
be to help facilitate not dictate but
facilitate the kinds of genuine
negotiations that will result in two
states living side by side in peace and
security and we have a limited amount of
time to achieve that goal
the Prime Minister's courage in being
willing to step forward up on behalf of
thing we had opportunity to discuss the
situation in Syria obviously we have a
broad set of strategic concerns in Syria
we are both pleased that there's the
possibility finally getting chemical
weapons stockpiles out of Syria but I
think we both share a deep concern that
we have to be able to verify and enforce
what has now been agreed to at the
United Nations chemical weapons inside
of Syria obviously and threaten Syrian
civilians but over the long term also
pose a threat to Israel and we want to
make sure that we get those
indiscriminant portable weapons out of
it and so will we are consulting with
the international community on these
issues and I shared with the Prime
Minister our belief that we have to move
with speed and dispatch and actually
making sure that the agreement that was
right at the United Nations has followed
through on in addition we have the
larger question of how to deal with the
civil war that's taking place in Syria
and given Israel's significant interests
in the spillover effects of activities
there we will be consulting very close
with that we had discussed Egypt I
shared with him what I said at the
United Nations just a week ago which is
that we continue to have concerns about
what has happened in Eden but we also
are committed to a constructive
relationship with Egypt in part because
the important role that returns David
Accords and the Egypt Israeli peace
served not only for the stability and
security of both those countries but
also for security in the region and US
security so we continue to work with the
Egyptian government although urging them
and pushing them in a direction in more
inclusive and needs the basic goals that
those who originally sought for more
freedom and more democracy in that
country and we had an opportunity
obviously to discuss a run both the
Prime Minister and I agree since I came
into office that it is imperative that
Iran not possess a nuclear weapon that
is important for American security it is
important for Israeli security it's
important for world security because we
do not want to trigger a nuclear arms
race in the most volatile region of the
world and given the statements and
actions from the Iranian regime in the
past the threats against Israel the acts
against Israel it is absolutely clear
that words are not sufficient that we
have to have actions that give the
international community confidence that
in fact they are meeting their
international obligations fully and that
they are not in a position to have a
nuclear weapon what I also shared with
the Prime Minister is that because of
the extraordinary sanction that we have
been able to put in place over the last
several years the Iranians are now
prepared it appears to negotiate we have
to test diplomacy we have to see if in
fact they are serious about their on
their willingness to abide by
international norms in an international
law and international requirements and
resolutions and we in good faith will
approach that indicating that it is our
preference to resolve these issues
diplomatic but we enter into these
negotiation very clear-eyed they will
not be easy and anything that we do will
require the highest standards of
verification in order for us to provide
the sort of sanctions relief that I
think they are locally so we will be in
close consultation with Israel and our
other friends and allies in the region
during this process and our hope is that
we can resolve this diplomatically but
as president united states i've said
before and I will repeat and we take no
options off the table including military
options in terms of making sure that we
do not have nuclear weapons in Iran that
will destabilize the region and
potentially threaten the United States
of America in all of us our unshakeable
bond with the Israeli people is stronger
than ever our commitment to Israel's
security is stronger than ever and we
are very much looking forward to
continuing to work with our friends in
Israel make sure that US security
interests are met Israel's security
interests of men but hopefully that we
can also bring about greater peace and
greater stability in a region that has
been wracked with violence and tensions
for far too long and I appreciate the
Prime Minister views he's always candid
and we're always able to have not only a
good working relationship in prime
ministerial level but also because the
outstanding work with our stats do so
this friend mr. Rock
president thank you for welcome to be in
my delegation and what I know is a very
busy day sir not even today many things
on my plate but I know that you know
American people know there is no better
out no reliable more stable or
democratic other than Israel in a very
broad beverages so I welcome the
opportunity that you're having to
discuss how we would closely together to
the press the enormous challenges that
face both of us and I I think of those
the most important challenge preventing
Iran from developing nuclear weapons I
appreciate beiträge of fact that you
made in Clinton remain committed to this
goal I also appreciate statement
amazement Iran's conciliatory would have
to be matched by real action experience
there are 50 meaningful life Iran and
committed to Israel's destruction so
presumably the opening
our future breathe with Iran is whether
or not Iran dismantle the community we
have a saying in Hebrew call it these
comic books are you would say in an
English what's the bottom line and the
bottom line again is that Iran fully
dismembered military nuclear program
unless regard I wanted to express my
appreciation to you for the enormous
work that's been done to you have
sanctions regime in place to thwart
Iran's pursuit of nuclear weapons I
believe that it's the combination of a
credible military threat and the
pressure of these sanctions that have
brought Iran to the negotiating I also
believe that if diplomacy is to work
those pressures must be kept in place
and I think they should not be less
until there is a verifiable success
in fact it is Israel's firm belief if
you are continues to advance its nuclear
program during negotiation the sanction
should be strengthened it's the
combination I believe that has guided
your policy and our policy so far
further credible military threat and
strong sanctions i thinkin still the
only formula that can give a peaceful
resolution this problem mr. president we
discussed many issues but I want to use
this opportunity to thank you Secretary
of State Kerry and others in the
administration for helping to advance I
remain committed to that and I hope that
our efforts are conifers would lead to a
secure and lasting peace we know that
proteins to endure it must be based on
visuals capacity to defend itself by
itself and I hope that we can achieve in
stark transformation and will give a
better future for us and our Palestinian
language and who knows one day with our
other neighbors as well so I want to
thank you again for your hospitality and
your efforts and it's very very good
I am not at all resigned and I'll have a
chance to speak more to this I'm going
to have seven meeting this afternoon and
may have some further thoughts for the
press as the day goes on but the bottom
line is that the Senate has passed a
bill that eats the government over does
not have a lot of extraneous issues to
it that allows us then to negotiate a
longer-term budget and address a range
of other issues but that ensures that
we're not shutting down the government
and we're not shutting down the economy
at a time when a lot of families out
there are just getting some traction and
digging themselves out of the hole that
we had as consequence of the financial
crisis I've said before Congress has two
responsibilities NASA budget pay the
bills and I am not only open to five
eager to have negotiations around a
long-term budget that makes sure that
we're investing in middle-class families
helping the economy grow if we've given
people who are working hard a leg up and
greater security and stability and deals
with some of our long-term challenges in
terms of debt and deficits but the only
way to do that is for everybody to sit
down in good faith without threatening
to harm women and veterans and children
where the government shutdown and
certainly we can't have any kind of
meaningful negotiations under the cloud
of potential default the first in US
history there's not a world leader if
you took a poll as we would say that it
would be responsible or consistent with
America's leadership in the world for us
not to pay our bills we are the
foundation of the world economy and the
world financial system and our currency
is the reserve currency of the world we
don't mess with that and we certainly
don't allow domestic policy differences
on issues that are unrelated to the
budget to endanger not only our economy
but the world is happening so I suspect
that I will be speaking to the leaders
today tomorrow and the next day but they
serve there's a pretty straightforward a
solution to this if you set aside the
short-term politics and you look at the
long-term here what it simply requires
is everybody to act responsibly and do
what's right for the American people
you